when the alphabet first popped up in the
Mediterranean it was a single scratchy
list of letters but now European
alphabets have not one but two symbols
for each letter
one big uppercase and one little
lowercase so I hear you ask why the
extra complications how did this
resizing happen gaze now with these
sternly romantic Latin and Greek
inscriptions with their textured words
that sink shallowly into their crumbling
slabs they look like epitaphs for an
ancient civilization but narrow your
aesthetic focus and look only at the
letters what do you notice
capital letters it's all capital letters
big imposing monumental capital letters
even when they took up softer media
writing on papyrus and parchment the
Greeks and Romans penned their words
with these big letters this majuscule
script
that's right centuries worth of all caps
rage but the rise and reign of
Christendom brought with it the ascent
of the book and books meant scribes with
ink flowing from their pens the large
sharp angles of older scripts gave way
to smaller rounder fluid forms in the
late 700 Charlemagne invited the scholar
Alcuin of York to his court and this man
shaped up the King scribes developing
and teaching what we know as Carolingian
minuscule the most celebrated early
latin minuscule or lowercase script
around the same time Greek writers came
up with our own running cursive hand
full of smaller minuscule letters to
Byzantine Greek had a particularly
strong minuscule tradition which
dominated its manuscripts for a thousand
years Latin and Greek weren't traveling
alone here Greek brothers cyril and
methodius tweaked their alphabet to make
it suitable for old Bulgarian in the
800s and so they gave birth to the
Cyrillic alphabet now Cyrillic never
developed the kind of very distinct
lowercase forms found in Latin and Greek
manuscripts but eventually it did
distinguish smaller and larger letter
types now at this point in our story
noticed that uppercase scripts and
lowercase scripts are different scripts
we're not really mixing magic skills
with mini skills here
when did the modern mixing start
bicameral scripts
ones that treat uppercase and lowercase
as variants of the same letter we're
still on the horizon you can get a hints
of the system in old writings like those
larger capital decorated initials that
adorn medieval manuscripts but bicameral
uppercase plus lowercase became the
standard when language is written with
alphabets settled on employing minuscule
for most text by using the majuscule
letters to signal important information
a big letter at the beginning of a
sentence a big letter at the beginning
of a proper name or even at the start of
every single noun these have all been
standards in the history of English and
the last one still is for German but not
all bicameral siblings agree should you
capitalize the name of a foreign
language or not can capitals fall in the
middle of words should you even
capitalize the first letter of every
sentence should you write some things
entirely in caps bicameral scripts don't
have a monopoly on different forms for a
single letter maybe we'll save the
details for another day because I always
like doing these comparative asides but
think about Syriac and later but very
similar to Syriac Arabic these cursive
scripts don't have capital letters but
each of their letters have up to four
distinct shapes initial when the letter
connects to the start of other letters
medial when it connects between two
letters final when the letters connected
to the end of other letters and isolated
when it's all alone there's even a cool
acronym for these they're in fee scripts
and well sometimes the difference
between IMF I forms is pretty small in
skirts that are is maniacally cursive as
Syriac in arabic it's very important so
huh maybe bicameral and in fee scripts
are both part of a broader phenomenon
how a single letter can have multiple
standard variants within a script but
still be the same letter in the same
script it's interesting to think about
it's a good question thanks for asking
it but now that we've tackled the
uppercase and lowercase letter variants
and now that the word bicameral rolls
off your tongue and makes you sound even
smarter than you already were I want to
move on to another story of latin letter
variants it's a tale of ancient and
medieval letter Motty modders
you